today we'll be speaking with josh dubin
who is a defense attorney and ambassador
advisor for the innocence project
a criminal justice reform advocate and
also host of the podcast wrongful
conviction
junk science uh josh it's so great to
have you on today
thanks for having me happy to be here so
to just to start with
um can you talk a little bit about how
you ended up
working uh in the area of uh
wrongful conviction and and sort of the
path that led you to that
sure um you know i'd always been
interested
in um criminal justice reform
and i got a call when
i was like in my late 20s
i had this odd path because i was known
as a jury
um as a jury expert so i would get hired
by criminal defense lawyers to help them
pick
juries um that was the way it started in
some
civil attorneys as well so i got a call
from
barry scheck um who
i had known from watching the o.j
simpson trial when i was in college
um i actually thought it was my brother
pranking me
um so i never returned the call and then
the person that the person that referred
me called me
his name is jerry leftcourt um who was
you know a civil rights icon he
represented
the panther 21 the black panthers at
that
their famous trial and abby hoffman
and he called me and said what what's
your problem i refer you to barry's
check and you don't call him back so
i called him back and um i met barry
and helped him with the case and um
it sort of took off from there shortly
thereafter
barry sheck and peter neufeld had a
civil practice a civil rights practice
um where they were beginning to
represent people that they had
helped exonerate through the at the
innocence project in their civil suits
and i began working with him and we
really hit it off and it sort of took
off from there
so big big picture um you can find all
sorts of different reports that that uh
claim one in 25 people on death row is
innocent
or some percentage there's all the sort
of different numbers that that are
applied
uh generally speaking to to folks who
have been convicted
and are in prison what is a good way for
the layperson
to wrap their mind around what portion
of people convicted for serious crimes
um are are actually innocent of those
crimes
you know it's difficult to tell because
you don't know
how many people are out there until you
take on their cases
so i don't put much stock into the
statistics but i'll give you one that i
do put a lot of stock into
and this is only dealing with one state
you know the state of florida has 29
exonerations off of death row 29.
um they have only executed
99 people in the state of florida
so i'm a shitty math student but if you
do the quick math
that shows you that a staggering
percentage of people that were sitting
on death row
awaiting execution um were
actually innocent i mean i was the lead
attorney
for clementi aguirre who was the 29th
exoneree from death row and i'm
currently representing
james daley who i think should be the
30th exoneree
um he's either going to be the 30th
exoneree or the 100th person
executed um so
i hope it's the former and not the
latter and i'm working real hard with my
team to make sure that that
isn't the case or that you know that it
is the case that he gets exonerated but
look
it's hard to know what percentage i
would venture to say
that it's much higher than people think
and
and it's a scary number um
because even one innocent person sitting
on death grows too much
so in interviews and documentaries i've
seen about the innocence project uh and
and with barry and peter one of the
things that seems very
important in so to set the context
the innocence project gets far more
requests than the number that they can
take in in terms of the number of cases
that can be handled many of these
cases take years uh to be resolved so
there's a there's a selection process
that happens there and certainly it's
important how strongly
uh correct me if i'm wrong you feel that
the individual in question
is innocent but how much of the calculus
again given that there are limited
resources and unlimited number of cases
you can take
how much of the calculus is about the
likelihood that you could actually
get a a conviction overturned
um that's a good part of the calculus
you know
and and different criminal justice
reform organizations have different
criteria for how
um they go about assessing cases and
whether or not they'll take them you
know i have a little bit more liberty
because i don't
work at the innocence project although
i'm i'm an ambassador for the innocence
project so sometimes i take on innocence
project cases
and that they're they're my first love
if you will um
but you know i can say that
different people do this work for
different reasons
some people take a look at a case and
say you know what
there are terrible legal violations here
uh constitutional violations and that
if you know there's something worth
fighting for here irregardless of
their assessment of a person's guilt or
innocence
um and for me that's important
and it's also important
to me you know i think that look we're
human beings
i think that the more i feel that
someone is innocent
the harder i think i'll fight whether on
a conscious or
or subconscious level so i think that
um likelihood of success
is definitely a factor but i can tell
you that all of these exonerations
are a an arduous battle
a steep uphill climb you're fighting
against very tall odds
um so um i hope that that was a
long-winded way of answering your
question
yeah i mean how how much does um a gut
instinct
factor into your belief
about a possible case a possible
a person you'll represent a client's
guilt or or
innocence how much of it is gut and how
much of it is reviewing the facts
i try not to let my gut
lead me in one direction or another and
i try to
to base it on on facts
or or absence of facts and there's a
very there's a very particular reason
why
i i sort of ascribe to that and and why
what is that
because it's got it's the gut of of
detectives and law enforcement
some some often times um
well-intentioned but extraordinarily
misguided that leads to the wrongful
um accusation in the first place which
leads to the core's confession which
relates to making up
evidence to make the the um
ends justify the means that you know
it's a it's a very dangerous path to go
down
because i'm often humbled by evidence
or the lack of evidence that conflicts
with my gut so i try not to let my gut
get
too involved and because again i think
that
you know it's oftentimes detectives um
feel like in their gut that if a spouse
is murdered
it's the surviving spouse that that did
it
and they started focusing on them
because that's their gut
and it can lead to tunnel vision and
confirmation bias and a whole host of
problems that
um are a pretty um
terrifying slippery slope for the
accused
there are a very long list of of reasons
and different ways
in which innocent people can end up
convicted and as you're talking about
uh tunnel vision from investigators can
be a way where
where somebody becomes the suspect
relatively early on at the exclusion of
maybe others
um junk science is another um
aspect of this and um for example
forensic dentistry is one that's been
explored
significantly and has been involved in
in a lot of uh retrials or or
exonerations can you talk a little bit
about how would you sort of categorize
the
the different buckets that would be the
main ways in which innocent people end
up convicted
yeah no that's a great question you know
one of the things it's also a natural
segue for me to plug the podcast but
you know on our podcast wrongful
conviction junk science
we explore a different discipline of
junk science on every episode
and it's not something that i'm plucking
out of thin air
i am doing it la in large part based on
the national academy of sciences
report in 2009 that examined
these various disciplines of forensic
dentistry
and essentially found that the only one
um
that that is reputable and has any
bankable
reliable science behind it is dna so
we examine everything from bite marks as
you mentioned forensic dentistry
to arson to um
you know
footwear impressions to ballistics
to gunshot residue to fingerprints think
about that
we have always been taught in pop
culture
on true crime shows that fingerprints
are the gold standard
and they're not um and if you really
examine any of these
um disciplines of forensic science you
find out that
even attaching the word forensic to it
or calling it a science is a misnomer
because
many of them are born in in basements
and
at the hands of some crackpot that did
not get
um even minimal buy-in from the
scientific community
much less apply the scientific method
and
they get accepted in one case and
because of our
our system of legal precedent they all
all of a sudden start spreading through
the justice system
and you know we get these um
you know various forms of alleged
science
that um you need a 40-hour
correspondence course to get
declared an expert in and you know you
you end up with
with real problems is there an asymmetry
with with a lot of this where as you
mentioned once
a certain type of so-called science is
accepted in a case it becomes precedent
for its future use
but on the other hand correct me if i'm
wrong if if such a
so-called science is found to be
unreliable in one particular case
there's no automatic process where
previous convictions are automatically
reviewed it's up to you
to actually bring these on a one on a
one-on-one basis is that is my
understanding correct
yeah that's basically it and it takes
look this 2009
report by the nas should have been a
bombshell
it was in the scientific community it
should have been in the legal community
and what it takes is attorneys with the
fight in them
um and and the um
you know the wherewithal to do the
research and to challenge it
but that's only half of it it also takes
a judge that has the courage
to not just follow legal precedent but
to take a fresh look at it
and oftentimes that's a real sticking
point
um judges like to follow legal precedent
they don't like to upset it
and it really takes you know attorneys
um you know really
beating the drum if you will as often as
they can and as much as they can
to try everything in their toolbox to
open the eyes of judges
and to get them to take a fresh look um
you know
we could take bite marks for instance i
mean
as a threshold matter the case that
allowed bite marks into our criminal
justice system
the appellate court said there's no
science here there's no way to replicate
it but who are we to upset what the
trial court judge did
well you're an appellate court that's
exactly what you're there to do but
nonetheless they allowed it in and you
know
think about this david there's no they
got
the the professed best
odeontologists in the country
odeontologists or these people that
fancy themselves forensic experts that
can you know match up teeth to a bite
mark they couldn't even agree on whether
or not a mark on human skin
was from human teeth um and
you know if you can't agree to that you
can
you know envision what some of the the
the problems are
downstream but you know they have found
in studies
that in reputable studies that are cited
in the nas
report that somebody could be missing
their front teeth
and bite down on human skin and it
appears
as if you do indeed have two front teeth
and people can have two front teeth and
bite down
and it appears that they don't have two
front teeth because of the size of their
incisors um so it's a it's a
science that's fraught with problems as
are many of these
disciplines of forensic science a couple
other things i wanted to ask about when
it comes to
a confession from someone to a crime
that they did not commit
and when you are working such a case
after a conviction how you overcome
that can you talk a little bit about why
people
would confess to a crime they didn't
commit it's very common for
individuals to say i would never do that
that i would just simply
never do that if put in a situation like
that what is it that that person can't
understand about how these things end up
happening
yeah you know it's probably the most
important question i've been asked
um and certainly you know you put your
finger david on
sort of the nerve root of the most
challenging issue
that i have studied for almost 20 years
now
you can say that until god forbid you're
put in the position
and you know the breakthrough that i
have had in getting people to understand
it is to get them
into the interrogation room mentally to
understand what's going on
and we are going to explore the the
flawed or the perversion of that
psychology in an upcoming episode of
wrongful conviction junk science the
tactics that are used
um but it is a very very very
effective combination
of of physical abuse
and and i don't mean just beating
someone up but
and psychological tactics that are
employed to get
someone to confess and you know it
starts with
getting them in a chair in a in a room
where there are no windows and cutting
them off from their support systems you
don't give them access to contact
friends or family members or to make a
phone call and you give them this
illusion that they're in custody
and a breaking down process occurs
sometimes over many hours or even many
days where you
cut people off from their
ability to contact the outside world you
start threatening them
you are permitted in the american
criminal justice system to lie to them
and to start telling them that their dna
has been found on something or what
would be the possible explanation for
that
um or that we have found a tool um
where we've been able to match the
markings on it to a tool in your garage
and
you know what's your explanation for it
and so it's a combination of that
and lying to them um about
what the implications are if they don't
play ball
um oftentimes they're able to convince
people
that their memory may not be um
as accurate as they think it is and when
you start to hear that your
fingerprints have been found somewhere
and your dna has been found somewhere
you start to question your own sanity
and it doesn't happen right away
sometimes it happens after you've been
deprived of sleep
after you've been yelled at and screamed
at um
after you have been deprived of food um
after you have been told
you know if you don't confess to this
someone very close to you is going to
suffer some serious consequences like if
you don't
play ball with us um somebody else is
going to suffer
trying to make people feel like they're
part of the investigation team
um how would somebody go about so if i
said to you david that
you know your fingerprints were found on
the murder weapon can you give us some
reasons why that could be
and then you might say something
innocent like well i do i have
used that knife before you know to cut
vegetables in the kitchen
um and then all of a sudden they have
these they have these
things that they can use against you
later on and they say well you did tell
us
you touched the knife and how are you
going to prove that it was the time you
cut the vegetables
and not last night fingerprints don't
have a time marking on them and it's
just this
constant breaking down process and for
many people that
that falsely confess
the thinking isn't okay i'll admit it
because i actually did it the thinking
is
these people are not going to accept
my explanation that i had nothing to do
with this for an answer
and now i'm scared and now i'm i
it's become apparent to me that they're
not going to take no for an answer
so i'm going to tell them what they want
to hear get out of this room
and sort it out later you know i have
had many clients
who the first thing they did when they
left an interrogation room
was go to a lawyer was go right to a law
firm
was to write a letter saying i only did
that because of what
was done to me in the interrogation room
so it's
it's in order to get people to
understand it you have to bring them
through it in painstaking detail
um i just gave you sort of a an overview
but we are going to be speaking to david
rudolph who's a really famous criminal
defense and civil rights lawyer he was
the
the um featured in the netflix series
the staircase
and he's done a lot of coerced
confession cases and we're really going
to dive into it
and you know in an episode a few weeks
from now
so that'll be in an upcoming episode of
wrongful conviction junk science we've
been
speaking with josh dubin who's an
attorney and also
host of the podcast wrongful conviction
junk science
josh i so appreciate your time the the
work is fascinating and important
and uh i i can't thank you enough for
being with us today
oh thank you so much for having me it's
such an important um issue and i hope uh
you know your viewers are inspired to
watch
to listen to the podcast